[Applause]
[Music]
nuclear power is like a hamburger yes
said you wouldn't have them anymore but
at the end of the day you just can't
resist the temptation the same goes for
nuclear power we all use it even though
it's a bit controversial
[Music]
if you've been following visual politic
for a long time you already know that
China has been building power plants
like there was no tomorrow well in
Europe we've actually got the opposite
trends going on and I know what you
might be thinking right now you're
probably thinking I mean come on Simon
everyone knows that France is the
biggest nuclear country yes well yes
you're absolutely right but even there
things starting to change inspectors
find safety irregularities at Chris Salt
nuclear forge in France in the United
Kingdom they wanted to build six plants
but in the end they only went one minute
early they held a referendum in 1990 to
stop nuclear forever and Spain might
close all seven of their nuclear
reactors as soon as they get old
this means they won't renovate them and
they won't build new ones so in ten
years
Spain might become a completely
non-nuclear country as well but this is
all rather small compared to Germany if
there's an anti-nuclear country its
Germany in three years they would have
closed all of their nuclear plants and
this is a big move in less than a decade
Germany will have closed 17 reactors
they used to rely a lot on nuclear power
but now essentially they're saying no
more and let's not forget that this
country is the biggest energy consumer
in all of Europe it has 80 million
citizens and plenty of factories indeed
it's the largest country in the largest
economy in Europe so the question is how
is Germany going to do away with nuclear
power I mean what are they going to use
to produce energy now and well who's
really benefiting from this anti-nuclear
policy most importantly is this really
good news in the fight against climate
change or not well today we're going to
answer all of these questions but before
we do let's take a look back at the
history
[Music]
Angela and her demons if nuclear power
is like hamburgers Japanese started
their diet in 2011 and you mind you
wondering well why I mean what was such
a big problem back then well let's
compare it to neighboring France France
has 58 reactors producing 75% of the
electricity in the country nevertheless
until 2011 Germany had just seventeen
reactors producing a little less than
20% of the country's total energy in
other words Germany didn't have any
reason to close its nuclear plants so
fast right why did it rush its
anti-nuclear agenda so much while the
answer lies in one word for Kashima
in the year 2011 a tsunami hits of
Japanese nuclear power plants the
Fukushima power plants this is how one
of the worst nuclear accidents started
and in all your thinking Japan might
have those kinds of problems because
they have earthquakes and tsunamis and
things like that but I mean Germany in
order to answer this question we have to
go back in time to the 1960s the 1960s
were the golden era for nuclear back
then Germany was divided into two
countries the capitalist West and the
communist East in the West
General Electric installed the first
plants soon German companies like
Siemens started specializing in nuclear
power and launching their own reactors
in the east by comparison the nuclear
plants were built by big state-owned
companies so yes the communist East
Germany was happy with nuclear power and
they had lots of reasons to be why well
they had their own uranium mines in fact
there was a time when eastern Germany
was the fourth largest uranium producer
meanwhile although the West had their
own minds they were too small most of
the uranium came from Canada and
Australia and this is how we come to
1986 what happens in this year well of
course that would be the year of the
Chernobyl accident
[Music]
this was the worst nuclear accident in
history way worse than Fukushima by then
Germany already had a big anti-nuclear
movements after years of protest they'd
already stopped some nuclear
construction projects and this is why
after Chernobyl anti-nuclear sentiment
grew in western Germany in fact one of
the conditions they required East
Germany to agree to for reunification
was the closure of all the nuclear power
plants for example at the time there was
a plant under construction in a city
called Stenzel they stopped construction
immediately and they haven't restored
the building since then basically after
Chernobyl nobody trusted Soviet security
at all but the story doesn't stop here
this German anti-nuclear movement became
a political party the greens' and watch
out because this party is very important
[Music]
they even had a coalition government
with the Social Democrats in the 1990s
do you member gerhard schröder well we
talked about him in some previous videos
so before he was working for Gazprom
when he was the Chancellor of Germany he
was supported by the greens and this is
why one of his policies was the complete
shutdown of all nuclear power plants by
2021 nevertheless in 2010 with Angela
Merkel's governments they changed their
plans while Schroeder said he would shut
down all of the country's power plants
by 2021 Merkel postpones the shutdowns
for 15 more years until 2036 so well
what happened next well again Fukushima
despite the fact that the authorities
checked piece by piece all 17 reactors
and found no security issues the
public's minds it was already made up
this is why Merkel changed her plans
three months to close the oldest
reactors in a few more years to close
the rest but okay so is it only
Fukushima or was there something else
well of course there is something else
the real key word behind all of this is
not Fukushima but fear and it's not fear
of radioactivity but fear of the
elections during the 2009 elections the
two main political parties in Germany
the Social Democrats and the Christian
Democrats didn't even win 60% of the
votes Germans didn't trust the
mainstream parties anymore
that's who capitalized on this mistrust
in mainstream politics well of course
that was the Greens in fact everywhere
in Europe the Greens are getting more
and more votes if you don't believe me
just check the outcomes of the latest EU
elections in 2019 and yes one of the key
goals in the Greens manifesto is closing
nuclear power plants as soon as possible
so Merkel decided that the best she
could do in this situation was to close
the nuclear debate once and for all in
2022 Germany will have no more nuclear
power period with this strategy she
hopes to make the Greens less and less
relevance if they have nothing to fight
against there's no reason to vote for
them any more right than any might
wonder well has this strategy works well
not really
Germany's fragile coalition braced for
upset with greens and far-right set for
more games in fact anti-nuclear
sentiment is also big business for some
people don't believe me we'll keep
watching nuclear 9
danke imagine that one day you start and
no hamburger diet and so eventually you
just say well I guess if I can't eat
hamburgers I guess I'll just eat as much
ice cream as I want one month later you
eat five ice cream cones day and you
wonder why you're still gaining weight
so well this is what happens in Germany
just listen to this country I think we
can pioneer the green energy revolution
we can as a powerful industrial nation
achieve the transformation to efficient
renewable energy the so called energy
vendor policy started this was the
energy transition basically Germany
would bet on renewable energies while at
the same time reducing co2 emissions to
fight climate change in eight years the
change has been radical nuclear went
from generating 22 percent of the
country's power consumption to just 12
percent green energy has gone from 17 to
35 but hold on a second because there's
another side of the green energy story
the truth is with the technology we have
today it's very expensive to store
energy
[Music]
solar panels produce energy during the
day Windsor vines produce energy when
it's windy but what happens on a quiet
night where do you get your energy from
in those situations a good alternative
would be natural gas but if you've
watched previous videos on this channel
you already know the political problems
with that one we've devoted a whole
series of videos to talking about that
issue and will continue to talk about it
so subscribe if you want more of that
the natural gas is bad because it would
make Germany even more dependent on
natural gas so if we can't rely fully on
solar winds or gas well what else do we
have on the list well yeah we have the
least green option of all
around coal wins a reprieve in Germany's
transition to a green future in fact
brown coal is one of the biggest issues
with this energy vendor about brown coal
is a type of coal that pollutes a lot
then again Germany is the world's
biggest producer of this so yes thanks
to the energy vendor Germany has secured
20,000 jobs coal companies gonna be
happier what's the price of all of this
but of course it's co2 emissions Brown
coal causes more pollution than any
other kind of coal so on today's Germany
Brown coal accounts for 23% of total
energy consumed in reality though it's a
lot more factoring in the coal that
Germany imports gets you to about 35% so
in other words if Germany's goal was to
increase climate change then well
congratulations Germany you did it
[Music]
Germany admits 2020 greenhouse gas
emissions target Fukushima and the Paris
agreement happens in a very similar
timeframe and Germany is showing the
world that if you're an industrialized
country you cannot close coal plants and
nuclear plants at the same time you need
to keep at least one of the two open and
if you thought the energy drama stops
there well you'd better think again as
we said in previous videos nuclear
plants are expensive to build but once
you have them it's very cheap to produce
energy using them so closing nuclear
plants means that the energy bill is
going to be wildly expensive after this
the fact that green energies are far
from cheap and you will get news like
this
[Music]
Germany's economic backbone suffers from
soaring power prices so now the question
goes to you do you think Germany will
keep their energy transformation even if
it means lower competitiveness for their
companies and what do you think is more
important climate change or anti-nuclear
sentiments and what would you have done
if you were in the German governments
would you close the coal plants or the
nuclear ones well please leave your
answer in the comment section below also
visit our friends from the reconsider
Media podcast they provided the vocals
in this episode that were not mine and
don't forget that we publish brand new
videos every week so subscribe to this
channel and hit that Bell button so you
won't miss any of our posts and if you
liked this video give us a thumbs up and
as always I'll see you next time and if
you want to learn more about politics
and hear more of my lovely voice don't
forget to check out the reconsider
podcast at reconsider Mediacom
reconsiders a podcast that challenges
you to reconsider your views by
providing context but we don't do the
thinking